AOC in the Congressional Hispanic caucus
were heckled yesterday after Democrats
toured the Roosevelt Hotel
which now is a shelter emergency shelter
for illegal immigrants
[Music]
close the border they're yelling at her
and of course in 2018 AOC led a movement
to abolish ice complete with photos of
the squad members crying outside of CBP
detention centers Arizona Congressman
Juan ciscomani joins us now to react
great to see you Congressman thanks for
being with us this morning you know do
you think when you see this reaction in
New York to AOC and her fellow
Congressional Democrats when it comes to
the border that it's a reflection of
um
elected representatives not representing
the interest of their people or is it in
fact they have represented the interest
of people who have voted for Sanctuary
cities
well listen what one thing that I've
been saying from the very beginning is
that with this border crisis every state
has become a border state and now we're
seeing it up in New York as well and
that reaction that you played is exactly
a reflection of that that's what we've
been saying for years now it's not even
months it's years now if New York is
feeling that kind of pressure imagine
what Arizona feels and this is a
reflection of the failed policies of the
left and it's not only this year or last
year but what's been coming and yeah the
you know people voted for these
Sanctuary cities and now they're they're
facing the consequences of that but the
blame is on the bite of administration
it's on Alejandro mallorcas who continue
to play a deaf ear to what's happening
even in in States like New York and
listen New York has been getting tens of
millions of dollars more than Arizona
has so so they and they're still in bad
shape now my job is to advocate for
Arizona when we're getting a fraction of
the funding that that New York is
getting and we just saw 13 000
apprehensions this week in the Tucson
sector that's troubling and this
Administration is not moving in the
right direction on that you know
Congressman you're right a lot of what
we've seen are images out of Texas but
right now it's Arizona that's being
absolutely flooded and there are new
images that show illegal immigrants
being detained in outdoor border patrol
holding areas in the Tucson area
facility is completely overwhelmed over
capacity we're hearing I'd be interested
in what you're hearing as well Mass
releases with notices to appear for
three four five years later they're
calling them Freedom runs I mean we're
they're just letting people out on the
street now
I'm telling you you're seeing this in
Ajo Arizona where people are being held
and and literally cages and outdoor
facilities now we're still seeing uh you
know over 100 degree weather in Arizona
right now you guys were talking about
fall weather in other parts of the
country not here we're still over 100
degrees and that's that's what's
happening and the street releases are
also happening all throughout Southern
Arizona uh County that I represent
Cochise County is seeing a big part of
that and this is now happening industry
just being released because these uh
ngos and all our departments as well are
completely overwhelmed and they don't
have any capacity so this is happening
and I'm telling you the morale of the
agents is low I go around town when I'm
back in the district like I am now
talking to parents and school functions
and grocery store and when I run into
the spouses of these agents they're
demoralized they they don't feel
supported they don't know what to do
they feel overwhelmed and underpowered
Congressman I'm happy to see that aoc's
constituents are holding her responsible
for what's happening to her own District
because of illegal immigration but
you're right she doesn't give a darn
about the you know what's happening in
Arizona which is a hundred times worse
than anything that's happening in our
district and she's not at those cages
that you talked about right there she
was there when Trump was in office when
he was trying to divide children from
adults so we could determine if they
were actually the parents or not but
when she sees this or the many trucks
that have come across this country with
people in the back as you said talking
about those temperatures people on the
East Coast don't understand just how hot
it gets in Arizona
um it's unbelievable why hasn't it
really quick why hasn't the media held
her more accountable
well what we have to do is we have to
stop uh we have to stop politicizing
this issue and we have to start
prioritizing it and that's what AOC and
others in Congress just don't understand
it definitely Biden doesn't and neither
does majorca's listen I'm a mimmigrant
I've gone through the process I know
this process better than anyone else in
Congress so I feel for the people that
are going through this situation too
Rachel I mean I'm an immigrant I went
through the process like I said I feel
that I pursued the American dream people
this is a humanitarian issue as much as
it is a national security issue but but
they they just don't get it and whatever
solution they think they're offering is
is off and then Biden and majorcus
continue to play a blind eye to it yeah
so right now the process is no process
and everyone suffers no process
Congressman Juan uh ciscomatti thank you
so much I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis